Elite distance runners have been closing
in on a two hour marathon for more than
a century but the sports last great
barrier has proven elusive for decades
the world's fastest times have fallen by
mere seconds at a time
that was until earlier this year when
Elliot Kipchoge a chopped a staggering
two minutes in 32 seconds from the world
two previous best time coming just 25
seconds short of the two-hour mark but
his time doesn't qualify for
world-record status
that's because capture gaez race wasn't
an official marathon it was more like a
carefully controlled experiment members
of Nikes breaking two projects spent
four years and millions of dollars
preparing three athletes for this race
optimizing everything from the shoes
they wore to the course they raced on
earth only cacio gain came anywhere near
breaking to understanding the science
behind capture gaez race helps explain
how he came so close and why this one
race could forever change the way elite
athletes run marathons one of the most
controversial elements of the breaking 2
project were the shoes Kip Cho gay and
the other runners ran in customized
versions of the vapor fly 4% a shoe with
a thick springy sole and a carbon-fiber
plate that Nike claims can increase
running economy by an average of 4% but
what does that 4% figure actually mean
and where did it come from I'm Roger
crumb I'm a professor in the integrative
physiology department here at the
University of Colorado Boulder and we
call this little commotion lab Nike knew
from internal testing that the vapor fly
was fast but when they needed someone to
check their math they called Crom his
lab is known for accurately measuring
the energy that athletes expend during
exercise we built this one also
ourselves in a machine shop when we
first built it it was the first force
measuring treadmill a postdoc named
voucher Hogue kamar led the
investigation comparing a prototype
version of the vapor fly to to other
shoes
the Nike streak six and the adidas
audio's boost two at the time the study
was performed these two shoes or their
predecessors had been worn in the ten
fastest marathons of all time an Adidas
shoe was worn by Dennis cameto and he
set the world record
now the audio is boost to wait about 50
grams more than either of the Nike shoes
Soho camera used lead pellets to
equalize the weight of all three that
way he'd know that any energy saved with
the vapor fly would be because of its
springy sole and carbon fiber plate not
its weight next the test subjects
performed a series of five-minute runs
in each of the shoes in different orders
on different days while the researchers
measured their oxygen consumption when
kromm's Team calculated the metabolic
cost of running in each shoe they found
about a 4% difference between the vapor
fly and the other two racing flats all
18 test subjects responded a little bit
differently but each of them used
between 2 and 6 percent less energy to
run in the vapor fly there are however
two big caveats number one Nike did fund
this research but it was a well designed
study and the data is pretty compelling
the second caveat the shoe is 4 percent
advantage applies to test subjects
running under ideal conditions for 5
minutes at a time but the extent to
which that advantage extends to an
actual marathon is still unclear look at
it this way a 4 percent boost in
efficiency should mean that a marathon
are usually capable of running a 2:05
race would be able to slip on a pair of
these shoes and run pretty close to a
two-hour race no problem but that's not
what we see in the real world which
suggests that something is lost between
a five-minute treadmill run and a 26.2
mile road race the truth is a marathon
boils down to a bunch of different
factors and what you wear on your feet
is just one of them
so what other variables can you account
for I think it's just a level of control
we had we controlled the course
extremely well because I think a lot of
the knowledge around optimum conditions
for these types of events is reasonably
well known I mean we did some we did
some fine fine tuning the racetrack at
Monza gave Nike the control to optimize
a bunch of factors known to affect
running performance like temperature
elevation nutrition even the turns in
the course all of which when added
together probably had a pretty big
impact on keep show gaze race take turns
for instance the more corners a course
has and the sharper they are the more
times a runner has to slow down or take
longer route which adds up to valuable
seconds over the course of a race the
same goes for Hills a flat course is
generally preferable to one with a lot
of ups and downs consider the Berlin
Marathon it only has a handful of sharp
corners and it's flatter than a lot of
other big city marathons like London or
New York these qualities make Berlin a
very fast course on average elite
runners finish 81 seconds quicker in
Berlin than they do at other races which
probably explains why every marathon
world record in the last 15 years has
been set in Germany the junior circuit
at Monza it's even flatter than Berlin
and has no sharp corners in fact the big
sweeping curves at Monza ensured that
Kipchoge a and the other runners were
always running the fastest shortest
route possible the looped course also
made it easier to deliver nutrition to
the runners at regular intervals along
the run about the only thing Monza
didn't have going for it was whether
running generates body heat and too much
slows you down cold temperatures helped
runners dissipate heat letting them run
faster longer numerous studies suggest
that the ideal temperature for
professional marathoners is below 50 or
even 40 degrees Fahrenheit but on race
day at Monza temperatures were a little
higher than ideal it was about 55
degrees and a little bit humid and I
wonder if they would have been able to
go faster if it had been 5 or 6 or 10
degrees cooler that's Michael joiner
he's a physician researcher at the Mayo
Clinic and an expert in human
performance in 1991 he published a paper
that predicted the ideal athlete running
under ideal conditions could complete a
marathon in one hour 57 minutes 58
seconds we asked him what he thought
made the biggest difference in Capshaw
his time and he had a very clear answer
I think the three aspects of breaking to
the contributed most heavily to the
performance are the drafting the pace
car providing a very steady pace the
whole way and also the runners who were
both causing the wind break but also
participating in the drafting in
traditional marathons Pacers have to
start the race with the runners and that
can only lead the pack as long as
they're physically able so they always
drop out long before the race is over
but for braking to Nike cycled teams of
Pacers in and out of the race over the
of the entire run in a finely-tuned
configuration never before seen in a
marathon to determine the ideal
arrangement for blocking wind Nike
worked with aerodynamics expert Robbie
Ketchel and the University of New
Hampshire to test pacing formations in a
massive wind tunnel they tried a house
configuration an inverted Olympic ring
and a wall shape with two rows of three
Pacers but the data showed the best
configuration was the Arrowhead shape
you see here that kind of advantage can
shave minutes from a marathon time but
what about the pace car in the days
after the braking to race a lot of
people speculated that the pace car and
the giant clock on top of it
was providing an even bigger aerodynamic
advantage than the Pacers which is not a
crazy theory the sign was big and the
athletes were running pretty close to
the car Nike and Ketchel say the car and
clock had a negligible effect on Kip
Tobias performance of course Nike would
say that but it's also probably true
aerodynamics engineers Stephen Ferguson
and Chris Beavis who are unaffiliated
with the Nike project ran a full
simulation of the benefits kept chaga
would have experienced in the wake of
the Tesla and the Pacers but according
to their simulations almost all of the
drag reduction came from the Pacers
Ferguson and Beavis estimate the car
clock and Pacers together might have
saved Kip Choga as much as four minutes
and 30 seconds compared to running on
his own but the car and clock saved at
most 26 seconds and that's under ideal
conditions on race day they might have
saved kept show gay half that as for how
the braking to project will affect the
way marathons are run in the future
every single expert we spoke to said the
big thing they expect to see going
forward are more coordinated pacing
efforts and/or if a team was unified
under the same country or under the same
sponsor then you had those four runners
who did co-op the term we came up with
it was cooperative drafting and if you
had cooperative drafting even in the
last fourth of the marathon or so that
could make a big difference I think the
other thing that'll be interesting will
be to see if you get team races team
Nike vs. team adidas or this country
versus that country sort of like you
have in cycling where people could work
together as sort of the running
equivalent of a peloton but the breaking
to project also shows that the two our
boundary won't fall from pacing alone
overcoming the marathons 120 minute
barrier will still require breakthroughs
on multiple fronts and so the arms race
between shoe companies will continue in
the form of ever lighter bouncier more
propulsive shoes expect race organizers
to optimize the conditions under which
marathons are run and most importantly
look for elite athletes like Elliot Kip
Shogun to continue pushing the limits of
what's humanly possible the hope for an
and under 12 was two minutes 57 seconds
now we are only 25 seconds away
[Music]